estamos en el problema número 11 y este
problema tiene unas letras aquí tiene la
letra zeta w la letra y y la letra x ok
en este orden y dice la serie siguiente
puede cambiar de dos maneras posibles
podemos cambiar esta serie de solamente
dos maneras la primera es que dos letras
adyacentes dos letras están al lado
intercambian su lugar por ejemplo aquí
puedo cambiar x con jay jay con x
intercambiamos un lugar a la segunda es
que las er y completas inviertan que
todo se invierta muy bien cuál es el
mínimo número de cambios que necesitamos
para poner en orden alfabético las
letras que tenemos
y de hecho déjenme recordar cuál es el
orden correcto de estas letras
l m n o p q r s t u v w x y y z w 1 x y
y z
aquí es donde queremos llegar es decir
que cuando lleguemos aquí ya encontramos
la solución mi intención es llegar hasta
acá perfecto y que se me ocurra ser
bueno pues podemos intercambiar letras
así que por ejemplo de aquí podemos
decir que tenemos setup w y voy a
cambiar x con jay jay con x me quedaría
x
no no no esto se ve muy tardado no no no
no no
esto no creo que sea la mejor opción que
podemos hacer cuál es el mínimo número
de cambios
mínimo número de cambios
fíjate bien si este w la pasamos al
final y lo invertimos creo que ya la
hice sí sí sí fíjate bien el primer
cambio sería lo voy a poner así el
primer cambio sería intercambiar w con
yen no va a quedarse tan bien w y x voy
a cambiar de lugar a estas dos a estas
dos para llevar a doble o hasta el final
y por cierto de una vez
el segundo cambio el segundo cambio va a
ser cambiar w con x y me va a quedar z
x y doble y y qué creés estos 2 100 se
parecen bastante creo que ya logramos lo
que queríamos porque también tengo otra
posibilidad la segunda posibilidad es
que la serie completa se invierta es
decir que todo esto todo esto se
invierta y me quedaría mi tercer cambio
mi tercer cambio sería invertir esto y
me quedaría w
y y ceta que es justo lo que yo quería
perfecto son tres cambios es decir que
para pasar de aquí para acá ya lo logré
hacer en tres cambios que era justo lo
que queríamos ahora serán los mínimos
esa es una muy buena pregunta serán
estos cambios los mínimos lo podrás
hacer con dos a ver déjame ver si yo
cambio a w para acá vamos a ver nuestra
segunda opción cambiar w para caer me
quedaría w z y i x y no aquí ya se ve
mucho más difícil porque la z la tengo
que llevar al final y entonces esto me
va a llevar muchos más pasos como unos 4
o 5 pasos no eso creo que no me va a
funcionar
no podría ser en una menor cantidad de
pasos
bueno parece ser que no de hecho yo
pondría de respuesta 3 que por cierto es
el inciso b 3 es el inciso b ahora no
estoy seguro si esta sea la respuesta es
decir si se puede hacer en una menor
cantidad de pasos a w w de hecho no
tengo que llevar forzosamente al final
doble uno pueden quedarse aquí si lo
llego al final para camps son dos pasos
y lo llevo al final para acá es un paso
pero sé que me queda ahí en medio
creo que la respuesta correcta e igual a
3 yo estoy casi seguro que esta es la
respuesta correcta y que esto no se
puede hacer en dos pasos entonces pues
vamos a votar por la opción número 3 la
opción número 3 que son tres pasos pasar
a este primero cambie v w x games
después w por equis y después invertir
si estoy casi seguro que esta es la
respuesta correcta
bien pues vamos en el siguiente problema
el problema número 12 el problema número
12 y este problema me dice cuántos
bloques cúbicos cada uno con una arista
de 4 centímetros
vamos a dibujar aquí tengo unos pequeños
bloques cúbicos y déjame dibujarlas los
tengo un cubo más o menos como éste
déjame hacerle un poco más grande tengo
un cubo más o menos como éste
así por lo tanto éste va para acá para
acá estaba para acá es un cubo se
trataba de hacerlo lo mejor posible pero
que cada uno de sus lados mide cuatro
centímetros este medio cuatro este
cuatro y éste también de cuatro muy bien
cada uno de estos lados mide cuatro
centímetros y yo lo que quiero llenar es
una caja rectangular con estos cubos y
la caja rectangular me dicen que tiene
las siguientes dimensiones déjame
hacerla por acá es una caja rectangular
un poco más grande algo más o menos así
aunque tiene las siguientes dimensiones
además tiene unas cierto largo por acá
ok
tengo algo por acá después tengo este
que me une a estos dos algo más o menos
así después está baja como por aquí aquí
está mi caja rectangular y déjenme a
borrar esto que me sobra
para qué dato confundas vamos a borrar
esto esto no me sirve ahorita eso
tampoco me sirve ahorita de hecho esto
tampoco me sirve ahorita
ok tengo mi caja rectangular y tiene las
siguientes medidas mide 20 x 24 por 32
cuantos de sus cubitos llenan esta caja
de aquí y bueno pues creo que hay dos
formas de resolverlo la primera es darte
cuenta que de ancho
caben cinco cubitos porque ese cada uno
de esos mide cuatro centímetros 20 entre
4 25 entonces de ancho caben cinco veces
de largo caben seis porque si éste mide
24 centímetros y cada uno de ellos mide
4 centímetros
aquí me caben seis de estos cubitos y de
altura me van a caber 4 a 32 entre
cuatro son 8 y por lo tanto soy
lamentable que multiplicar 5 por 6 que
es 30 30 por 8 240 cubitos 240
ok esa puede ser una de las formas para
resolver este problema otra de las
formas sería sacar el volumen de este
cubo y decir bueno 4 x 4 x 4 son 64
centímetros cúbicos
este es el volumen de este cubo y cuánto
tiene esto de volumen bueno pues esto
tiene de volumen 20 por 24 por 32 lo que
sea que sea esto ya esto dividirla en
364 y por suerte y estoy seguro que
llegaría a 240 también pero pues fíjate
que aquí hay que hacer más matemáticas y
más aritmética prefiero la forma
sencilla ya está vamos el siguiente
problema cambiemos de color y dice
problema número 13 si en esta entre 0 y
es decir que 0 es menor que en el menor
que uno dice ordena de menor a mayor
la raíz de n coma n o n cuadrada y bueno
creo que ya hemos resuelto varios
problemas así cuando tengo un problema
sí que te parece si nos tomamos un
número entre 0 y 1 vamos a decir que en
el vale un cuarto vamos a suponer que
vale un cuarto y digo un cuarto porque
un cuarto tiene una raíz cuadrada muy
fácil de sacar la raíz cuadrada de un
cuarto por cierto la raíz cuadrada de un
cuarto es un medio sacamos raíz arriba y
raíz abajo bueno de hecho es más menos
un medio más menos un medio pero estoy
casi seguro que se refieren a la raíz
positiva de un cuarto que es un medio
entonces este déjame techarlo aquí y
bueno cuánto vale n cuadrada pues n
cuadrada es lo mismo que un cuarto al
cuadrado lo cual es 1 sobre 16 y yo lo
que quiero ordenarlos es del más chico y
el más chico es 1 sobre 16 1 sobre 16 al
más grande me queda 1 sobre 16 1 sobre 4
y 1 sobre 2 es decir encuadradas el más
chico después decir que en él después de
así que en la raíz de n muy bien y por
cierto la forma de ponerlos así es el
inciso
en el cis hoy ya tenemos el número 13
vamos el número 14 este estuvo bastante
fácil número 14 problema y tenemos la
figura de a continuación así que déjenme
hacerla lo más rápido posible espero que
no esté tan difícil
voy a hacer aquí mi eje yo voy a hacer
aquí mi eje x ok
vamos a poner que estos son nuestros
ejes este es el eje y este es el eje x y
luego tengo aquí este de aquí es mi
valor de 3 y por otra parte aquí tengo
con 3
5 y por acá está el 6 y sigue muy bien y
después de unas ciertas rectas tengo
esta recta de aquí esta recta de aquí y
después tengo esta recta de aquí esta
recta de aquí más o menos me quedaría
algo así después tengo esta recta de
aquí y me quedaría algo más o menos
así como para después tengo esta recta
de aquí esto de aquí me va a quedar algo
más o menos así tengo que sobre un poco
más algo más o menos así y la última es
una recta más o menos así algo así y me
dicen que esta recta se llama am expert
dejar cambiar de herramienta esta recta
se llama a esta vez esta se está de
fiesta
y lo que me preguntan es cuál de las
siguientes rectas de estas rectas que
tengo aquí tiene como pendiente la
mediana de las pendientes la mediana
diana y ojo recuerda que la mediana es
el valor que está justo en medio es
decir no hay que confundirla con el
promedio o con la media aritmética la
mediana es la más sencilla porque porque
estamos tomando el valor que está justo
en medio y bueno creo que por aquí suena
muy lógico decir que el valor que está
justo en medio es sep porque si te das
cuenta la recta es la que tiene la mayor
pendiente la recta es la que tiene mayor
pendiente es la que más inclinada está
mientras que por otra parte la recta es
la que menos inclinada esta es la que
tiene menor pendiente y por lo tanto la
que está en medio es la c es decir que
mi mediana es el valor desde este estaba
muy fácil mi respuesta sería c y espera
y está me preguntan cuál es la pendiente
pues recuerda que la pendiente es el
cambio en que con respecto a x o dicho
de otra manera vamos a comparar que
todos todas de éstas tienen el mismo
cambio en james lo que cambia es el
cambio en x sin embargo la que está
justo en medio es el inciso sé que es
esta
y si te das cuenta esto tiene un cambio
en x de 4 es decir hay que dividirlo
entre 4 y tiene un cambio en james de 3
todas las tienen un cambio y en tres de
hecho es una constante y por lo tanto
arriba va 3 la pendiente de la recta c
es tres cuartos que es mi respuesta ya
está nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo